his name will be called I'm gonna guess
relatively soon coming up Thursday night
Josh Rosen former UCLA quarterback who
joins us now
courtesy of Old Spice Josh good morning
thanks for joining us where are you
today absolutely thanks for having me on
I haven't Dallas at the moment just flew
in last night okay so what's the game
plan the game plan is hanging out the
Old Spice guys today promote their
premium sense with all all the fancy
prices I'm gonna hang out with them for
a little while
family's coming in tomorrow and take it
from there how different or strange is
it to get paid for something now where
is a couple months ago you couldn't get
paid for you know doing a commercial
read for Old Spice it's it's really
crazy I mean the first time I ever got a
professional check was a pretty cool
moment it was actually for like the
Dallas out that actually in Dallas
ironically enough the all-star challenge
that we were doing and it was just it
was kind of cool actually I actually
ended up saving the cheque but um it was
a really cool experience they're finally
basically a sport that I've been I've
been busting my bust my blood for since
third grade is actually sort of coming
to fruition and actually giving me
something legitimately financial in
return
okay wait you say you did you frame the
cheque or you're gonna cash the cheque
what are you gonna do with it so I'm
trying to get a copy of it I'm working
on it and so yeah so yeah I had to
deposit at the bank I was working on
getting the cops back all right how's
this process been it's been awesome I
mean I learned a lot it's it's tiring
it's definitely a lot more than I don't
really think anyone you don't really
understand what it is until you're a
part of it I mean with all the flying
around visits combine programming from
an outside from an outside perspective
looking in you kind of just you see the
combine you're right they went out there
for like a day or two
did that pro deck okay I went back to
school hung out and then it kind of
seems like it's done from there but
there's a lot more that goes into it but
it's really cool because I get to meet
someone
lievable people from all around the
country I mean you need a ton of
different other players from all
different kinds of schools some coaches
have been part of some football games
that I remember growing up watching as a
kid and team executives that I mean
you've been here and there's their names
since I've started playing football so
it's a really cool experience it's tough
it's long tiring a little bit but it's
all worth it do you care about being
liked as strange as that's gonna sound
and I'm just talking about how you're
assessed because you have strangers who
are assessing who you are you know the
last month or two months media people a
little bit I mean you can't really
stress about it too much but I think the
biggest thing at least on the football
field is I want to be respected I want
to come off the field and I want to
shake their middle linebackers hand I
want to shake one of their their their
top DBS and he goes you played a hell of
a game both ways and I want to be
respected I want to get out in the field
in the NFL and I want to play and I want
to earn the respect of my opponents my
teammate yeah I just I I was talking to
my guys prior to the show and I said I
don't know why it feels like people have
gone out of their way to be critical of
you or more critical you and Baker
Mayfield it feels like that instead of
looking at the positives that looking at
the negatives there how tough is it to
read these mock drafts or you know
however they size you up on where you're
going and and what you don't do well you
know I think a little bit of that too is
because Baker and I've been kind of out
in the spotlight for a little bit longer
than some of the other guys yeah I've
been playing for about three years and
Baker Baker's been really in the
spotlight for about two years he's been
kind of he's been playing for a couple
cents with with his whole story behind
being a walk-on so he's kind of just
been out there longer had longer
exposure I mean some of the other guys I
think Sam play for about a year and a
half
Josh played for a year really in a
spotlight I mean Lamar also he's been in
spotters for two years I think basically
maybe it's a little bit of on just
exposure I think we're just kind of out
there a little bit more but we also I
think have
a bit of different personalities I think
we kind of have a little bit of moxie to
us that helps us on the field and
sometimes off the field some guys take
it the wrong direction or what but
that's that's not up to up to us to
determine how other people view us I
love I love the word moxie so it's
old-school you know people can't have a
problem with moxie you know they can
when you're cocky or something like that
but you say I know I got some moxie
there so I think I picked up on some
McCoach more yeah how many teams have
told you they're going to take you it's
a lot more indirect than that some of
its if you're there we'll take you or
some of them like it let me let me play
you and then you show me that you have
you they speak in code okay all right
all right now I'm gonna be you you speak
in comfortable deniability okay they say
anything they want without actually
getting in trouble okay well how do they
hint to you that they're gonna take it
if you're there a lot of it's on the
visit sometimes sometimes it's
straightforward sometimes it's not
they're saying like a key maybe may have
a starter and they're a little bit
deeper in the draft and they're like hey
we really really like you maybe if you
fall out of a curse certain couple picks
we might try to try to trade up and get
you or something like that or some teams
at the top they have a whole different
sort of gamut of decisions but I mean
it's all it's all fluid I mean I just
hope I get picked on the first day I am
well her vinson yeah it's actually but
like I I think that you kind of have to
take every day for what it is and
regardless of whatever team tells you
what they're going to do it doesn't
matter because whether they told you or
not you're going to get picked by a team
and if one team told you a couple days
earlier they were gonna pick you it's
kind of irrelevant information Josh
Rosen joining us on behalf of Old Spice
red collection of premium sense he's
getting a paycheck for this the new
captain designed to help guys everywhere
step up their scent game
breaking the bank learn more about the
red collection at Old Spice comm
favorite quarterback growing up was who
favorite quarterback growing up Peyton
Manning and as of recently as Payton
retired Aaron Rodgers now my guy you
worked out with Aaron did me a couple
times yes I did what was it like it was
unbelievable it was really really really
cool I mean I was a huge Aaron Rodgers
fan I think he he's just he's just a
different kind of guy
I didn't kind of player and watching him
is is just it's really cool it was
really cool to throw with him kind of
pick his brain a little bit but yeah it
was a really awesome experience
you guys have similar personalities like
I find him really sharp inquisitive I
think people aren't sure if he's you
know being serious or cocky or what like
there's a there's more to Aaron but you
know I've gotten to know him and I can
see or hear some of the traits with him
in you well I mean I think you kind of
do have to have a little bit of an
attitude I mean he kind of saw him an
old UCLA guy Anthony bar actually that
knocked him out of that game you kind of
saw a little bit Aaron's attitude and
huh
working back in them and I think you
have to have that it's a very violent
sport and you've got a lot of different
personalities on a team and you need an
alpha dog in the locker room and if you
don't you're gonna get to the part if
you're a passive guy I'm not saying you
need to be at like a motivational speech
guy but you have to people have to
respect you and you put the foot down on
the field you have to you have to be
confident in your abilities and
absolutely supremely confident that when
you throw a ball it's your team and
receiver that is going to catch it all
right I want you to clear up a couple of
things and it can be brief with your
answers here did you say that you didn't
want to go to Cleveland at any point no
I did not okay how important is the
Jewish community for you and where
you're going to be drafted
it will be it will be important wherever
I am drafted but it's not putting any
value over one place or another I mean
it's my it's my culture it's my heritage
I was I was born and raised Jewish and
I'm proud to be Jewish but that's
football is a different beast though
those don't really play into one another
give me the story behind the hot tub
that we don't understand because I I
think it sounded like you were having
fun and it was meant to be fun or funny
and it didn't turn out that way yes I
mean I we're just basically those are my
enrolled early as a freshman I was in a
single and then I got an apartment with
a little bit of a living room and we're
just kind of thinking think funny things
to do with it or what to put in there
and we just thought of putting a little
inflatable hot tub in there and actually
messed up because my preset address on
Amazon was to my mom's house so she
actually called me goes did you just
apply a hot I was like yeah you know
what I actually did that's great and so
she's really she actually ended up
driving it up and I thought that was
permission right there so put it in the
room had it for a little bit and yeah I
mean it's and then basically was in
there for a couple weeks and then after
I think I played really well at the cow
game and got a couple followers pretty
quickly and I think someone noticed it
but I mean it's probably good that it
got found because it was pretty humid it
probably would have fly to let's ride on
electronics anyway where is that hot tub
now that hot tub I really I couldn't
tell you I could not tell you maybe it's
a Morris had a very swiftly remove it
yeah I'm gonna guess your full name full
name
my full name Joshua Ballinger Lippincott
Rosen all right quick explanation of
that so JB Lippincott Joshua Ballinger
Lippincott is my great-great-grandfather
and he started the JB Lippincott
publishing company in Philadelphia
that's an old publishing company that
has been around for a long time
I think they did like a lot of medical
books or whatever but basically my dad
out of his last name and now it's Joshua
valve your lip and Carozza I like that
good luck with the Jets Josh you're
gonna like it here in New York and
there's a Jewish community here and we
can get you a hot tub is what I mean
they got it all for you here if that's I
don't know how you look in green but
you're gonna love you're gonna love the
Jets
I appreciate I'll be happy to play
anywhere that takes me as long as they
picked me on Thursday have fun with it
and you know what it'll be over quickly
and then you'll be able to move on yeah
but that's you've survived you know you
you got 48 more hours to survive I think
you I think you can pull it off hey guys
thank you so much that's so Josh Rosen
joining us on behalf of red collection
at Old Spice dot-com for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]